es uno de los momentos más cruciales
para Dina boluarte desde que asumió como
presidenta de Perú tras comparecer ante
la fiscalía por un tema que la ha
perseguido desde que juramentó el abuso
policial en las manifestaciones
pido perdón por esta situación y por lo
que no se haya dejado de hacer para
evitar esos acontecimientos trágicos
desde ese ocho de diciembre de 2022 Día
de la juramentación la acompañó una
oleada de protestas
como rechazo a la nueva presidenta y
exigiendo elecciones escenas como esta
se han repetido
y muchos han tenido que enterrar a sus
seres queridos tras morir a manos de la
policía durante las manifestaciones
Y es que a pesar de que el gobierno se
ha mantenido firme en negar la
existencia de estos abusos poco a poco
organismos internacionales los han
denunciado desde mediados de diciembre
al inicio de las protestas la cidh
anunció una visita al país debido a
hechos a preocupantes en las
manifestaciones el 10 de enero amnistía
internacional pedía el DC inmediato de
la violencia contra los manifestantes y
solo unos días después la Unión Europea
y la oea manifestaron su preocupación y
tacharon los hechos de intolerables no
se pueden aceptar actos de vandalismo y
mucho menos un uso desproporcionado de
la fuerza por parte de las autoridades y
represión en las manifestaciones
violentando la vida humana especialmente
sobre las poblaciones que han sufrido
desigualdad y estigmatizaciones el 31 de
enero la cidh condenó oficialmente el
uso arbitrario de la fuerza por parte
del gobierno y a lo largo de febrero
Perú Recibió la condena de otras
organizaciones lo que llevó a la
fiscalía a abrir una investigación en
contra del gobierno en el que boluarte y
su gabinete tendrán que explicar la
muerte de decenas de personas a manos de
la policía